hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over the
entire illustrious and super enthralling
swordsmith village arc of demon slayer
this arc takes place within the hidden
swordsmith village and gives us some of
the most amazing context as to the inner
workings of the demon slayer world i
really enjoyed making this video and its
counterpart the entire entertainment
district of demon slayer so if you
haven't seen that yet and want some
context as to what happens exactly
before we arrive at this point in the
story then make sure you go and check
that video out so you understand what
exactly is going on and don't miss out
on any vital information also if you
lovely people want to get early access
to all of these kind of videos in the
future along with some super special
extras then make sure you go and check
out my patreon which i'll leave down in
the description below as honestly that
helps me more than you can imagine and
lets me know that i can spend more time
on these kind of videos to make them
even better for all of you obviously you
guys don't have to do that though as
i'll still make them either way because
honestly i just love doing this so if
you still are eager for these kind of
videos just in general make sure you hit
that subscribe button as well and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
it helps out with that silly old youtube
algorithm but anyway enough of that sit
back relax grab a bag of popcorn as this
is going to be an absolute banger where
you are constantly left wondering what
could possibly happen next goto a male
member of the kakushi who are the
cleanup brigade of the demon slayers is
seen walking down the halls of the
butterfly mansion while he walks through
the halls he reveals that two months
have passed since the end of the battle
at the entertainment district kikushi
remembers how badly injured everyone was
especially tanjuro hoping that the smell
of his castella will wake the comatose
tangero he is left completely stunned
and infuriated when he walks in to
discover a shattered vas on the floor
noticing kano he announces the food that
he brought and asks her to clear a free
spot for it tanjudo then wearily thanks
goto for the dessert leaving him
completely stunned so much that he drops
his entire dish he then angrily bursts
out kano for not saying that tanjudo had
regained his consciousness and comically
abuses her for her silence before
running into the hall to summon everyone
keo sumi and nahu shed tears of joy
after discovering that he has awakened
but are then immediately frightened when
aoe comes flying into the room after
untangling herself she begins to sob at
his bedside and tangier finds out that
zenitsu had woken up the day after the
battle and had just left screaming and
crying before going on a job tengan the
sound hishera left after the battle
being carried away by his wives despite
his terrible injuries when tanjido goes
to ask about inosuke he is told by aoi
that he has been horribly poisoned and
that inosuke was on the verge of death
while she's explaining tanjuro begins to
wonder if he was hallucinating or not as
he spots inosuke hanging on the ceiling
everyone in the room then looks up in
horror to witness inosuke crawling
upside down on the ceiling he loudly
praises tan pachero for noticing him on
the ceiling anloski drops down onto
tanjido's bed then brags that he woke up
a week before him and how he had poison
resistance making him in his eyes
immortal onosuke gloats about having an
apparent immortality and is swiftly
corrected by goto that he is just simply
a because of this a fight ensues
between the two and aoi rushes to break
it up as the bickering gets louder kanu
tries to quiet the room down until she
has to tell the other two to be quiet as
tangido has actually fallen back asleep
anosuke immediately worries that tangido
has returned into his comatose state but
the others assure him that he just needs
to get more rest a week goes by with
tanjuno making a full recovery and
enosuke embarking on a new mission while
tanjuro works on improving his weakened
stay he asks kio and naho about his new
sword but to his complete dismay they
show him the angry scratched drones of
hate which clearly depict that the
swordsmith would not make tanchito
another sword now distraught keo tries
to upload tangido by saying that hotaru
has been the difficult one and he should
try to meet with him at the swordsmith
village to discuss it in person tanjulo
ends up asking for permission to visit
the village in which kagaya allows him
to go he sends a new kakushi to take him
she informs him that in order to keep
the village safety hidden tangent must
be carried there and will have to put on
a blindfold plug in earplugs and
especially plug his nose throughout the
journey tangier was frequently passed on
to new kikushi while the crows are also
swapped in an effort to maintain the
location secrecy once tanju arrives at
the village he is amazed by the sense of
the hot springs he loudly shares his
gratitude towards the kokushi for
transporting him which echoes loudly
through the hot springs his voice is
eventually heard by the love hashira
mitsuri kanroji who is bathing in a
nearby spring once at the swordsmouth
village tanjura was greeted by the
villager's chief titchen titchen
kawahara who dubbed himself the best of
his craft in the village teaching
discloses to tanjido that the village is
currently looking for hotaru haganizuka
after he disappeared a few days prior
tanjudo comments on his swordsmith's
cute name which techn reveals that he
himself gave him that name the chief
notes about how hotaru had always had a
bad temper and with tanjudo attempts to
apologize for fueling this temper
through breaking his swords titran
refutes it by stressing that hotaru
should be creating swords that wouldn't
break he reassures tanjuro that they
will bring hotaru back or alternatively
have a different swordsmith fortune and
new blade titian then suggests that
tangier relax in the hot springs while
advancing to the hot springs tanju runs
into matsuri kanroji who had just
returned from that said hot spring
kinroji complains about how she was
ignored when she was asked for an
individual's name at the spring tangero
calmed her by revealing that the
villagers were almost done with the
dinner for the guests which mitsuri
excitedly hurries off to at the springs
tanger was suddenly hit with a tooth and
is surprised to encounter ginya
shinozugawa he excitedly jumps in the
water and tries to converse with his
fellow demon slayer but is saddened
after genya angrily strikes him and
storms off back at the village tanjulo
praises mutsuri for the amount she is
capable of eating declaring that he
himself would also try to eat lots and
grow strong he then brings up genya with
mitsuri sadly observing how the boy must
be tsunami zugawa's younger brother
given that they share their last name
despite the win hashera telling her that
he didn't even have one tattoo asks why
she thought it was pitiful and while
playing with nezuko matsuri replies that
she herself had five younger siblings
and had a good relationship with all of
them the two chat and both hope to
someday be able to have a nice
conversation with genya and tanju
decides to bring him his leftovers since
he didn't come to dinner as they walk
through the corridor with niziko tanju
inquires matsuri on the reason why she
joined the demon slayer corpse
embarrassed she states that she wanted
to find a man to marry someone who was
stronger than her and could protect her
as she goes on about her thoughts tanjo
listens in disbelief the trio are then
approached by kakushi who informs
matsuri that her new sword will be
really soon and that she should check it
out so that it could be adjusted if
necessary the hashira bids farewell to
tanjuro and praises him for his hard
work expressing her approval for the
siblings after tanjuro declares that he
will be sure to defeat mozart matsuri
happily hints about a secret weapon
hidden in the village that could make
him even stronger the next day tanjuro
searches through the forest looking for
hotaru and ponders about the secret
weapon mitsuri told him about
in the distance he suddenly hears two
individuals one of them being the mr
shira muchiro tokito behind the trees in
the forest tangero worriedly watches as
a young child yells at the mrshera
proclaiming that he wouldn't hand over
his ki and his knowledge to him muchiro
suddenly strikes and grips the boy much
to tanjuro's horror as he races over to
restrain muchero's wrists in an attempt
to force him to let go despite having a
smaller and thinner body composition in
intangido mushiro does not budge and
asks for tanchiro to release his hold
quickly punching him in the stomach and
calling him weak when he does not do so
the hashera then senses a demon in
tanjiro's box but he slaps his hand away
and saves the boy in the process when
the boy continues to nine muchero the
key he insults him and the other
swordsmiths stating they had no worth
besides making swords and this
conversation was currently wasting him
time that could be used to save people
angry at muchero's degrading words
tanjaro hits him and expresses how he
was too cruel to the child while he
states that he does not deny the
accuracy of his words tanjo stresses the
importance of these sword smiths and how
they too are fighting along with the
demon slayers albeit not on the front
lines mageiro cuts him off and hits him
in the neck knocking him out cold right
before losing consciousness tangero
notices hotaru hiding behind a tree
while unconscious tangier has a
conversation between the child and
hotaru but the latter runs off as soon
as tanjiro begins to regain his
consciousness after picking himself up
tanju excitedly inquires whether hotaru
was just there which the boy nervously
denies the boy also reveals that he gave
the key to muchiro which tanjiro
apologizes for intervening as it wasn't
his place to he's thanked however for
standing up to the hashera in order to
defend a complete stranger the two
converse and the boy informs tanchiro
about the key's use which is to operate
a deteriorating mechanical doll that had
been built by his ancestors and was used
for swordsmen to train with in the
middle of their conversation the two
suddenly heard loud sounds the boy leads
tangido over to where muchero is
intensely training with the battle doll
dubbed yodewichi type zero while
watching tokito train against the doll
tanjo looks at the doll's face and
ponders the idea that he has seen it
before confused as to its appearance
tanju asks why it has six arms in which
he is told that it was modeled after a
real swordsman the dole's six arms were
necessary to imitate the swordsman's
unrealistic movements tanjuro tries to
push for more information but the boy
apologises and states he didn't know
much else besides that it originated in
the sengoku period surprised tanjido
notes how that must mean that the
yoruichi type zero is over 300 years old
and even so it still hadn't been
destroyed the boy replies that his
ancestors were able to construct the
doll at a level that couldn't be
accomplished again at the present time
hence its durability and that he
wouldn't be able to fix it himself
especially without the aid of his late
father given that he himself doesn't
possess the knowledge or skills to do so
because of this tangier realizes the
reasoning behind his resolve to not hand
over the key to someone who could
potentially destroy the doll while they
continue to observe muchiro for a while
longer tangible admires that he shares
extraordinary degree of skill despite
being of a similar age material's crow
chips in and refers to him as a
descendant of the sun breathing users
and a genius leagues different from
tanjuro surprised by his bloodline
heritage he curiously asks why muchero
wasn't able to use sun breathing which
receives him an angry assault by the
crow while being attacked by the crow
tajiro suddenly remembers the dream he
had and how the swordsman he saw had a
face that matched that of the dolls
hearing his words the crow stops and
grumpily questions the logic behind his
words given how the swordsman was from
so long ago the young boy pitches in
proposing that perhaps it was a memory
that was passed on providing the example
of a swordsman inheriting memories from
their swords and skills from their
ancestors suggesting it may be similar
to what tanjuno was experiencing the
crow thinks of this idea as nonsense but
cuts it off as tanjuro introduces
himself to the boy and the boy
introduces himself as kotetsu suddenly
the group hears a sound and witnesses
muchero destroying parts of the doll
with pieces of the armor flying away
devastated at the side kotetsu runs away
and hides in a tree crying over the
broken doll tanju finds him and attempts
to motivate him by saying he'll
eventually be able to improve and fix it
in which kotetsu replies that he is too
pathetic to do so but hearing this
tanjuro climbs up the tree and flicks
kotetsu as a method of snapping him back
into reality exclaiming how he had to
make the effort and develop the skills
so that even if he wasn't able to fix
the yoruichi type zero the generations
after him would be able to do so tangelo
compares his struggle with kotetsu's
affirming that even if he dies before he
is able to accomplish his goals someone
else will eventually be able to do so in
his place as long as the framework is
said which is similar to what was said
during tanjoro's dream flashback by the
mysterious man
cheered up kotetsu and tangero conclude
to determinely work hard together while
they chat during a walk through the
forest they encounter muchero again who
expresses that the training was helpful
however his sword broke so he will be
taking one of the dole's swords he
tosses the broken sword indifferently to
tanjuro asking him to discard of it at
first confused by the swordsman's
attitude tangero realizes he lacked a
malicious intent and likely wasn't
acting rudely on purpose tanjiru rushes
to kotitsu who appears saddened while
staring at the broken doll in the rain
tanjulo suggests they check if it can
still move which is met by approval from
the boy as they pick it up it remains
stagnant for a few moments before
suddenly shifting into a stance randomly
kotitsu then fiercely orders tangero to
train with a doll and become stronger
than muchiro with his aide tanju begins
to train with the yoroichi type zero
while ketetsu uses his analytical skills
and newfound motivation to excessively
critique the demon slayer's movements he
states that until tanjiro can accomplish
what he wants he will not receive any
food kotitsu shows tanchiro another
method of adjusting the doll's movements
through twisting its fingers such that
it'd coordinate with the user's
weaknesses and compares the actions to
that of plane with a wooden puzzle box
after readjusting the doll tangero
continues brutally training with it
still without food water or sleep under
kotetsu's direction just as tanjuro
approaches the brink of death comparable
to nearly crossing the sanzu river which
is similar to the great concept of these
sticks but in japanese mythology because
of this almost death moment he becomes
capable of smelling the incoming
movement of the doll and lands a hit on
it earning him his first meal in a few
days after gaining this ability to
predict movements tangier continues to
train with the doll and improves his
stamina and four sides in the middle of
his spa with a doll tangero's newly
improved abilities grant him an opening
to be headed however he hesitates
mid-swing and worries about breaking the
door but kotetsu yells at him to strike
reassuring him that he would be able to
fix it internally the young boy begs
tanjido to not waver so that one day he
will become stronger than anyone else
with kotichu's approval obtained tangido
succeeds in landing a blow to the doll's
neck and breaks his sword in the process
he apologizes to kotetsu for the ruined
sword but after kottitsu's sudden
exclamation tangero turns to see a
hidden swords held emerging from the
doll's body where the head used to be
these swords held appearing out of the
doll stadls tanjido and kotetsu who
shout in shock their surprise quickly
shifts to fascination and excitement as
the peer attempts to deduce the age of
the blade kotetsu urges tanchiro to take
the sword but tanjuro is adamant on the
fact that he could not and the dull
breaking to make it appear wasn't
completely his doing kotetsu insists as
the owner of the doll that he is the
final say and that tanjiro should take
it especially considering how he needed
a new blade anyways caving in tangero
pulls out the blade as kotetsu watches
excitedly in anticipation but they are
disheartened after seeing that their
blade had rusted with its age kittitsu
tries to apologize to a tearful tanchiro
for getting his hopes up but they are
suddenly interrupted by a muscular
hotaru haganezuka emerging from their
words hotaru mentions that he heard
their conversation and tries to take the
sword from tanjiro and kotetsu they try
to get hotaru to explain why he is
acting this way but the swordsmith
continues to try and take the sword and
finally forces it out of their hands
kozo kanamori appears behind hotaru and
tickles his sides making him fall limp
kozo greets tanjiro and kotetsu and goes
on to explain hotaru's situation he
states that hotaru had been remotely
training in order to improve his forging
skills so that he could make a strong
sword for tanjiro that would not chip or
break in which tanjuru happily admires
hotaru's thoughtfulness kozo continues
on saying how tangiers repeated requests
for swords from hotaru made him happy as
he lost many of his clients with his
personality while they chat hotaru
suddenly regains consciousness and
confidently declares that he will fix
the rusted blade while kotetsu fusses
over how he could have easily just
explained that before they fought over
the sword the next day tanjiru talks
about hotaru's progress on the sword
with genya who is angered by tanjiru's
presence and attempts at friendliness so
he tries to get him to leave when he
starts yelling tangido notices that the
tooth he had pulled out a few days ago
had reappeared he questions him on this
and shows the tooth that he had picked
up as proof discussed in genya and
resulting in him being kicked out of the
room saddened tanjore ponders his fellow
demon slayers consistent anger somewhere
else as the calm night continued a lone
swordsman strolls through the village
after a bath and encounters a pot
mysteriously placed on the ground
curiously he reaches for it but is
suddenly engulfed by the pot killing him
gyoko the upper rank 5 emerges and
comments on the disgusting quality of
these swordsmiths as meals elsewhere
upper rank 4 hentengu cows on a roof and
cowardly states that they must quickly
accomplish their mission an asleep
tanjido is woken by tokito pinching his
nose the mr shira questions tangido if
he knew kozo kanamori's whereabouts as
he was his new swordsmith tanjido
mentions that he was likely with hotaru
and offers to help find them mature asks
why tangero would willingly accompany
him when he had many other things to be
doing and tanjulo replies that he
believes helping others would positively
benefit him at tangido's words tokito
feels a strong sense of familiarity and
questions him on what he just said the
demon slayer tries to reply but is hit
by an awakened neziko breaking muchiro's
perception seeing nezuko mature comments
on her uniqueness and wonders we had
seen her before while tanjulo worries
about the chachamaru tamio's feline
assistant that it appeared before them
the trio keep thinking about their
respective worries when suddenly tangido
and muchero sends a presence behind the
door when they glance over hantengu
crawls into the room without radiating
his presence as a demon surprised
tanjiru and muchiro both realise
hantengu is an upper ranked demon and
prepare to attack with muturo
immediately using misbreathing fourth
form shifting flow slash but hentangu
swiftly dodges to the ceiling and cries
begging the demon slayers and not to
hurt him tangier tells himself not to
hesitate and uses hotado's newly forged
blade to attack hintengu with henokami
kagura sunflower thrust hintengu dodges
again but receives a blow from nizuko
who's in her awakened form realizing
this tangier tells nezuko to not
transform fully while at the exact same
time muchiro successfully beheads
tentengu tanjuna remembers that
beheading an upper rank does not
necessarily result in its death based on
his prior fight with daki and guitaro
and tells muchiro to keep his focus
right as he does the seventh head and
the body transform into two new demons
one of which holds a leaf-shaped fan
mushiro attacks the demon with the fan
while tanjuro takes on the other as
muchero rushes to attack the demon waves
his fan at him and intensely blasts
monsieur out of the building tanjunu and
niziko managed to hold on to the rubble
and come face to face with the two
demons kiraku asks his partner sakido if
he was having fun in which sakira
responds negatively and uses his staff
to emit bolt of lightning-like attacks
which slowly make tanjido lose
consciousness but just before he does he
sees genya on the rooftop pointing a gun
directly at sekito ginyu shoots both
sekiro and karaku with his nichiren gun
blasting off sikhido's head and nearly
decapitating karaku karaku expresses his
enjoyment towards the fight as genya
rushes in to slash off his head with a
maturing sword but as he does this
tangero yells at genya that his attacks
were futile and the demons were
willingly being beheaded so they could
keep splitting and increase their attack
power tanjunu begins to desperately
analyze his opponents and tries to
pinpoint their weaknesses but his
thoughts are interrupted by a third
bird-like demon a rogi who lifts him up
into the air with his foot realizing
that each demon has a unique ability
tangible instructs nezuko to insist
genya however horrified he realizes that
genya had been impaled by a fourth demon
aizetsu orogi taunts him for worrying
about the others and not himself
proceeding to generate a sonic scream
tanjuro attempts to counter with
hinokami kageta and successfully cuts
off a rogue's leg but is unable to dodge
his scream and is violently struck with
the attack as he falls he plummets
through trees and lands on the ground he
pleads with himself to get up and
protect the village but his injuries
render him incapable of easily moving
isetsu lands near him and holds his leg
down as he directs another shriek in
tanjido's direction elsewhere muchiro
dashes through the forest as he makes
his way back to the village he spots
kotetsu trying to hold off a minion fish
demon and internally decides that he is
not a priority to save but as he hears
the cries of kotetsu while the demon
grabs him muchira remembers tanjido's
words of how helping others would
positively benefit him he slashes the
fish demon's arm releasing kotetsu and
stands over the boy while requesting for
him to run so that he would not be in
the way mature slashes the fish demon
and decapitates it but it regenerates he
tries breaking the pot stationed on the
demon's back and subsequently makes it
disintegrate the hashera then realises
that the port was the source of the
power for the demon likely the result of
a blood demon art as he continues to
think a crying ketsu ambushes him with a
hug and thanks him for saving him the
hashira tells kotetsu to leave as he has
to make it back to the village kotetsu
begs him to not go since kozo and hotado
were under attack while hotaru was
finishing a blade machero tries to turn
down his request but he hesitates when
he hears kagaya yubishiki's voice in his
head who tells him to rediscover himself
surprised at the pause mature thinks
back to when he had gotten amnesia after
being saved by kagaya who had told him
not to worry about the memory lost and
that the mist in his head will
eventually clear out with matters that
seem unimportant at first convinced
maturo carries kotetsu with him as they
search for kozo as they continue through
the forest mature begins to doubt if he
was doing the right thing as the village
was still in danger however he pushes
the thought away and reminds himself
that he is the mr shearer acknowledged
by his master in the forest near the
edge of the village tangero dodges an
attack from arogi by slicing his head
splitting him into two more demons the
pair of demons generate more sonic
screams and direct them at tanjuro but
the demon slayer is able to withstand
them and observes that hantenku is most
powerful at four separate demons that
represent the four primary emotions any
more splitting would decrease their
attack strength with this information
tangible continues to attack orogi and
is slashed across the chest with a demon
sharp claws but manages to land multiple
blows on his head back in the building
neziko struggles against karaku sakiro
impatiently asks for his partner to
defeat her and azitsu volunteers to land
the final blow however as izetsu
attempts to pull his spear out of genya
the demons that point his gun at him and
blast off his head sakira berates izitsu
for his foolishness after genya shoots
off his head and the demon responds by
forcibly pulling the spear out of genya
mortally damaging him he comments on how
this spear lodged in kenya's body had
prevented him from dying after it had
his vitals points and now he will perish
ignoring him kenya quietly chants the
amida sutra which is recognized by
azitsu angered at the delay sequito
yells at azitsu to kill genya but the
demon slayer dodges his spear and
attacks azetsu from behind with a
natural sword however before kenya can
cut the demon's head he gets blasted
from sequito's lightning and becomes
incapacitated
though he manages to hit zaquito with a
bullet azitsu responds by hitting him
with his spare shaft noggin him into the
wall still struggling against nezuko
karaku gleefully watches his companions
fight and then impales nezuko through
the stomach with his foot he gives
instructions to sikido and pulls
neziko's arm off but he receives a hefty
kick from her and nearly loses his head
using blood demon art nesiko proceeds to
burn karaku and pulls herself from his
grasp when karaku is yelled at by
sequito she takes his fan and blows him
out of the building she tries to do the
same thing with aikido but he sticks his
staff through her neck and shocks her
with bolts of lightning paralyzing her
back in the forest tangido continues
fighting against hirogi who continuously
slashes him with his talons tanjo forces
himself not to panic and makes it a
priority to return to the building
internally telling kenya and nezuko to
keep holding on ginya recovers from
being hurt into the wall and continues
muttering the chand surprised that he is
still alive sakido questions him smiling
ginya holds up his gun and tells him his
name stating that he will be the one to
kill him while tangero continues his
fight against orogi he considers using
the demon's flight ability to escape the
forest and return to nizuko and genya
after finalising his plan tanjiru stabs
the demon in the mouth after being
picked up and uses the force to smash
into the building's exterior wall
completely destroying it tangero picks
himself up in time to see cicado
paralyzing mizuko when he dashes to save
her saketo generates another staff and
tries to hit tangido but the boy uses
aroki's foot to defend himself and
prevent the lightning from reaching him
he then slices the demon's head and
tongue stalling for some time to pull
the staff out of nezuko's neck suddenly
tangero gets slammed down on the ground
with his second staff and is about to
receive a shock of lightning but niziko
recovers in time to burn cicada and
prevent him from hurting him relieved
that neziko's blood demon art is
effective he looks up to see karaku saw
through the air and hit the building's
floor with enough pressure to bought a
hole through it and render tangido and
nezuko unconscious the demons then
regroup and gaze over their opponents
planning on dealing the final blow in
the depths of the forest tokito defends
the fish demon and saves kozo after a
reunion muchiro requests for kozo to
provide him with his fixed blade to
replace the chipped one he is currently
using kozo agrees that mushiro needs a
new blade and mentions that it was
tanjudo who asked him to fix the old one
he leads the mrshira and kotetsu to the
shed where haganezuka is currently
working kozo explains that he has a
sword for machero and is shed and after
he receives it he should immediately
head back to the village to protect the
chief monsieur denies this proposal and
pulls kozo back when he tries to advance
towards the shed he tells him he senses
something and instantly sees a pot
rattle in front of him emerging from the
pot gyoko the upper rank five comes out
and identifies tokido muchero as a
hashera for realizing that he was there
gyoko introduces himself to tokito
kanamori and kitsu and asks for a brief
moment for he kills them he calmly
presents his art piece titled death
throes of the smiths which consisted of
multiple mangled smiths and blades
passed through their bodies the demon
starts describing his detailed work
while the horrified kozo and kotetsu
name the swordsmiths gyoko taunts them
by their reactions and twists one of the
swords resulting in one of the
swordsmiths screaming out in pain
aggravated by his demonstration matura
attacks kyoko but he retreats into his
pot before the hashera can cut him he
reappears in another pot on the shed's
roof and mature notes his ability to
switch between the parts then slices up
the one on the roof gyoko swiftly
switches to yet another pot appearing
out of thin air on the ground and
expresses the great irritation at mature
for destroying his artwork the demon
summons a couple of fish demons which
surprise machero with blood demon art
thousand needle fish killer and kyoko
showers hundreds of sharp needles at him
the swordsman manages to dodge the first
onslaught of needles but is forced to
take multiple hits from the second
attack of needles to protect kozo and
kotetsu he tells the civilians to get
away as the fish continue to attack him
gyoko stands on the side and laughs at
muchero's appearance which consists of
multiple needles sticking out of him he
reveals that the needles contain poison
and chides him for having to die because
he saved insignificant people gyoko's
words spark an intense sense of
familiarity to muchero as he tries to
remember where he had heard them before
suddenly recalling a hot summer day in a
small abode the demon expresses his
eagerness to create a nice sculpture
with a sharer but is interrupted by
muchero attacking him gyoko uses blood
demon art water prison pot to surround
his opponent with a pot-shaped prison of
water rendering him unable to breathe or
attack as his blade could not pierce
through the layer of water he laughs at
his predicament and proclaims that the
12 kazuki desire to weaken the demon
slayers and reach kagaya yubishiki
nearby a crow cores through the night as
matsuri kanroji runs through the forest
she tells herself to hurry and
enthusiastically states the convenience
of the swordsmith village being close to
where she was stationed in the village a
group of swordsmiths try to defend
themselves as a fish demon approaches
them matsuri kanroji arrives and slashes
the demon killing it she apologizes for
her late arrival and heads towards the
chief's residence at tejun's location a
swordsman tries to save him from being
crushed by a fish demon but his injuries
rend him unable to move masudi appears
right before him and instructs him to
stay still to prevent his injuries from
becoming worse the lavishera then
attacks with love breathing first form
shivers of first love slicing the demon
and making it release the chief after
defeating it matsuri angrily mutters how
those who hurt others will never make
her heart throb as tichen falls from the
demon's grasp she manages to catch him
before he hits the ground crying she
begs him to wake up and after a few
coughs he comments on how he was caught
by someone so cute relieved to see that
he was alright matsuri quickly goes to
help the others that were wounded
elsewhere tanjuro suddenly awakes to
hear the voices of huntengo's various
forms he looks to see neziko carrying
him through the building as she dodges
bolts of lightning and tanju remembers
that they were previously knocked
unconscious they get hit with a shock of
lightning and tangerine manages to
defend niziko and himself from urugu
swoop running out of the room sakiru
yells at kiraku for being too slow and
tells him to use his uchiwa fan to
destroy the building to which he agrees
the pressure from kraku's fan attack
makes the building collapse with nezuko
caught inside the mess she grasps onto
tangero's blade making herself bleed
while tanjuro begs for her to let go and
says he will find a way to move the
rubble but she refuses to stop holding
the blade and uses her blood demon art
to cease it on fire tangido notices the
blade burning from the heat and is
shocked to see it change colour from
black to red as it gets enveloped in
flames all of a sudden through an
inherited memory tangero sees an unnamed
man and woman comment on how a swordsman
with earrings had a blade that was
normally jet black but somehow turned
red when he was in combat tundra links
the swordsman's blade with his own
noticing the similarities and their
colour changes and how his was thanks to
nezuko's blood demon art he pushes
himself to ignore his body's fatigue and
injuries and tells himself to meet the
expectations of those who have helped
him so far the three demons belittle
tangible and rush towards him to attack
but they see the red sword and muzan
kibijitsu's memories trigger the forms
recognize the red sword as one used by
the demon slayer that nearly killed
their master and as tanjiru swings his
sword back his motions greatly resemble
those of these swordsman stunned the
three forms are all then slashed with
the hinokami kagura dragon sun halo head
dance after decapitating him tanju
recognizes the fiery sensation when
cutting down the three demons as the
same one he felt when he dealt the final
blow to guatara at the entertainment
district he goes to look for hantengu's
last form izetsu and sees him impaled to
a tree with his own spear as genya
shinozugawa stands in front of him
holding the demon's head tanjiru's
relief over genya's safety and the
defeat of aizetsu quickly switches to
horror as genya turns to reveal the
demon-fired face his thoughts are
interrupted by a yelling karaku who
complains about his inability to
regenerate and the burning sensation in
his wounds tangero feels uncertain if
defeating the four emotion demons is the
correct way to finish the upper rank
four and at that moment he smells a
fifth body he tries to think of how to
find it but kenya grabs him declaring
that he will be the one to defeat the
upper rank four and become a hashera not
tanjido realizing that genya has not
succumbed to the demon instincts tanjuro
and niziko give him full support of his
goals much to ginya's surprise their
conversation abruptly ends when cicada
blasts lightning towards them tanjoro
splits up with genya and izuko to run
off and find the fifth body sugenya can
be the one to behead him he rushes
around and desperately searches finally
spotting the body cowering and quivering
behind a bush he hears it muttering
encouragement to himself saying the
emotion demons would defeat the slayers
tangelo gives directions to genya about
where to find the fifth form of hantengu
and asks nezuko to provide him
assistance he then is nearly swept away
by karakou's wind attack nesico attempts
to slash shakedow before he can release
lightning on her brother but she gets
impaled by z2 spear tangero hinders
kato's movements by cutting off his hand
holding the staff and the demon notes
tanjiru's exceptional battle adaption
skills orogi is slashed by the flaming
blade and niziko grabs izitsu enveloping
him in fire and burning him kuroku
counters tangita by slamming his fan and
forcing tanju to the ground with
pressure however before he can again
attack his arm falls off and he curses
tanjuro for cussing it's genius receives
some more directions from tanjudo as the
latter yells them out and he desperately
keeps searching for the fifth body after
more continuous searching genya spots
hantengu behind the bushes shrunk down
he shoots him with his gun but the demon
dodges and runs away while pursuing him
ginya inwardly chastises the demon's
wimpy nature and swings at his neck with
his maturing sword he pushes himself to
force the blade through hantengu's neck
but his sword suddenly snaps due to the
demon's thick neck he tries shooting
again with his gun to no avail all of a
sudden cicada appears behind ginya and
aims his staff at his neck distressed
kenya remarks that he cannot regenerate
his head and is about to die but before
he gets struck he thinks of his elder
brother sunimi and how he wanted to
become a hashera so he could apologize
to him for something that had happened
between them kenya thinks back to his
past where his small and weak mother
would often be abused by his father
alongside himself and his siblings one
night kenya notices that she was late
coming back even after their older
brother sunimi went to look for her he
calms her siblings and tells them to
sleep but they suddenly hear a knock on
the door kenya tries to tell them not to
open it in case it was a stranger but
they ignore his warning and are
immediately slashed upon reaching it
ginyu is also cut across the cheek and
he states in horror at a figure grasping
onto the ceiling within the darkness
preventing him from identifying it
suddenly saneemie appears and tackles it
out of the window while yelling at genya
to run terrified ginyu checks the status
of his siblings and tries to cover their
wounds despite their bodies already
being cold when he runs off to find a
doctor he approaches an injured sunimi
standing over the corpse of the
demon-fired mother dismayed at the site
genya runs over to cradle his mother's
body and his arms and cries calling
tsunimi a murderer genya after
remembering this past internally
apologizes to his older brother for a
shock that overwhelmed him to the point
of labeling sanemi as their mother's
killer even despite the struggles that
he must have had to protect him by
killing her esekito aims for genya's
neck the demon slayer thinks of all of
his regrets and flaws a memory of sanemi
is a heshera declaring that he had no
brother sad and scanya and he thinks
about how he wasn't able to reach a
share of status to earn the right of
apologizing to him right as cicada
scrapes ginya's neck with the staff
tanjudo appears above them and saves him
by cutting cicada's neck he shouts at
ginya to not give up reminding him that
he was supposed to be reaching for the
goal of a sharer and that he should only
think about beheading hantengu as
tangero finishes speaking he notices
izetsu approaching him from behind the
demon uses its blood demon art weeping
spears to attack tangido but he is
shielded by genya who gets impaled and
multiple spots on his body ginya tells
tanjudo that he should be the one to
behead hintengu and tanjuro willingly
accepts dashing over to hantengu and
hitting him with his flaming sword as
tajiri makes contact with his neck
hentengu lets out a piercing scream
tanjoru puts pressure on his blade and
attempts to force it through hentinger's
neck the demon continues his high
pitched screaming but tangier refuses to
waver suddenly a dark figure appears
behind him and tanjunu notices that it
does not smell like any of the previous
emotion demons opting to ignore it he
tries to behead huntinggu but his sword
loses its power from nezuko genya aims
at the figure behind tanjido but he is
unable to shoot without possibly hitting
his teammate the mysterious demon hits a
drum and a giant dragonface tree
immediately sprouts nezuko barely
manages to jump in and save her brother
losing one leg in the process she
immediately regrows it right before they
land but suffers a massive loss of
energy as tanju to make sure she is safe
the demon begins talking and names the
negative emotions that individuals who
are pure evil emit specifically those
who harm the weak infuriated kanjiru
realizes that they are now six demons
but notices he can't sense the previous
four genya witnesses the appearance of
the sixth demon and alarmingly
reaccounts how it used to be the anger
demon ciquido however after tanjiru
struck hantengu's neck skado had
forcefully absorbed his three
counterparts and transformed into the
childlike demon in front of them the
demon hits another drum and wraps
hantengu within his tree trunks
shielding him
tanjulo tries to stop him but he and
genya are both held back by the pure
strength of the sixth demon's aura a
result of hantengu's power growing as
the situation worsens the demon labels
them as evil and when tanjaro demands an
explanation as to why he replies that
the label is reserved to those who try
to hurt the weak furious at his words
contradicting the fact that he had eaten
hundreds of innocent humans tanjo loudly
vows to cut him down
still trapped in gyoko's water prison
pot tokito thinks to himself that he has
enough air for one more attack
proceeding to use missed breathing first
form low clouds distant haze but his
attempt is unsuccessful and without any
more air in his lungs he accepts his
fate thanking kagaya yubishiki for his
support and wishes him luck finding
someone to replace his ashira position
however he is surprised by a vision of
tanjuro who tells him that nobody knows
what the future will be like a statement
tanjido had never said to him in the
nearby shed kanemori gets slashed by
gyoko as he desperately shields hotaru
from the demon unaware of their presence
hotari fixates on restoring the blade
given to him by tanjudo and mutters
about the incredible quality of its
craftsmanship goku observes him
confirming that he is not the chief due
to his age the demon calls out to him
but hotaru does not respond and
continues muttering about the
eccentricity of the blade a level of
concentration that astonishes kyoko
jealous of otaru's fixation for his
craft kyoko slashes him multiple times
and summons another fish demon that
attacks kozo hotaru continues to ignore
him and his mask falls off from the
attack revealing his face and kozo
rushes to try and snap him out of this
trance goku vows to break the
swordsman's continuous persistence
outside mature loses his ability to
breathe tangible's vision keeps
appearing in front of him and expresses
how muchero himself would decide his own
fate muchiro dismisses his words but
tanjiru continues and informs the mr
shearer that someone would come to save
him although he tries to disclose his
distaste for relying on someone else the
vision of tanjido tells him that
sometimes he has to rely on others as he
cannot do everything on his own mature
listens to his remarks and berates
himself for not working hard enough to
prevent mistakes from happening and
additionally for overestimating himself
suddenly a knife enters the water and
kutetsu begs muchero not to die as he
futilely struggles to pierce the prison
matura tries to get him to go protect
the chief rather than worry about him
but kotitsu persistently keeps trying
one of gyoko's minions appear behind the
child and slashes at him as he runs the
demon uses its claw to stab kotetsu
seeing this attack mochiro deems the boy
is dead however kotichu stays standing
and returns back to the water blowing
air into it and transferring a breath
from him to machero as much inhales the
air he remembers tangero's words about
how helping others would in turn help
him and connects his words to a man
maturo's father freshly motivated the
hashera uses missed breathing second
formed eight-layered mist and
successfully destroys the water prison
as he escapes the prison tokusa realizes
that tanjiru's eyes are the same shade
of red as his father's mochiro pulls out
the needles numbing his face and begins
regaining more of his memories
remembering that his father was a
woodcutter kagaya yubishiki's soothing
words enter his mind and he sorrowfully
thinks about his master's disease as he
crawls to kotetsu cutting apart the fish
demon that had attacked him muchuro's
memory progression continues as he
recalls his mother's death from illness
and his father's death from falling off
a cliff when he tries to speak with
kotetsu machira suddenly remembers about
his older brother yuchiro tokito his
twin and sole companion after their
parents death when they were 10.
thinking back to his past mature recalls
yuchiro's blunt personality after they
were orphaned and how he ridiculed their
father for trying to save their mother a
man who had died when aiming to help
others crying mature unsuccessfully
attempts to get yuchiro to stop
insulting their father and instead
received insults from him regarding the
first character in his name moo which
could literally be interpreted as
nothingness the twins continue to live
together despite this strange
relationship which mature had attributed
to his older brother potentially
despising him after surviving on their
own for a while the siblings were
visited by kagaya's wife who had told
them about their swordsman heritage
angered by her presence yuchiro drove
her away and intensely berated muchero
after he had expressed his interest in
becoming a swordsman straining their
relationship to the point of forfeiting
any communication between them one
summer night a demon entered the twins
home cutting off yuchiro's left arm and
insulting the sibling's lack of worth
angry muchiro to the point of releasing
an explosive rage the boy managed to pin
the demon down and crush it watching it
disintegrate as the sun rose crawling
back to euchiro maturo witnessed his
brother's final words begging the gods
to spare machero as he was a good person
that desired to help others unlike
himself as muchero held his brother's
hand he told him that the mo in his name
was actually meant to represent the moo
and mugen
finally recovering his memories mature
awakens his true strength and gains mr
like markings all over his face as he
powerfully grips his blade finally
receiving his demon slayer mark yuchiro
apologizes to his brother for his
inability to be nice to him and that he
truly tried to protect him clutching his
hand as his memories are shifted back to
reality in the shed goku was infuriated
to see hotado continuing to work on the
blade despite the numerous injuries that
he had inflicted on him including the
loss of one eye on the side kanemuru
struggles to move and gyoko goes to
finish him off but is interrupted by
mature's attack surprised at his escape
from the water prison kyoku sees these
strange markings on his face and
realizes it is similar to the boy with
the hanafuda earrings that muzan had
told him about the boy's composed face
and attacked speed despite being struck
with paralyzing needles earlier bothers
the demon as muchuro rushes in to attack
again anticipating that gyoku uses his
blood demon art octopus vaz hell octopus
legs fill the entire shed and trap
muchero as they destroy the building at
the last moment kozo gives muchiro his
mended nichiren sword outside hosaru is
knocked aside from the attack but pays
no mind to it as he returns to
sharpening his blade his stubborn
persistence puzzling the demon gyoko
opts to temporarily ignore the
swordsmiths and instead focus on muchero
as he wraps him and kozo within his
attack exclaiming that he will crush
them despite gyoku's claims that the
octopus is too powerful to be cut
machiero cleanly slices through it and
releases him and kozo mature thanks the
swordsmith though kozo denies stating
that he simply followed the instructions
from his previous swordsmith mature
thinks back to a conversation with the
aforementioned swordsmith tetsuedo and
when he had expressed deep concern for
his client after learning how hard he
had worked and how difficult it was for
him to cope with his memory loss
eternally apologizing to him for causing
worry matura tells tetsueto that he is
alright and proceeds to use a
misbreathing fifth form sea of clouds
and haze to cut apart the rest of the
octopus's tentacles goku watches it and
praises him for his speed but retorts
that this swordsman will not be able to
catch up to his pace however majira
refutes his warning and suggests that
the demon senses have become sluggish
then a confused gyoko witnesses his neck
he cut from the hashera's previous
attack angered kyoko tells him not to
underestimate his string matura said
that his rival's looks are absolutely
disgusting and that he thinks he
scurries around in filth which angered
gyoko who tells tokido to shut up but
suddenly as gyoko speaks machira notices
something about the demon's pot he tells
him that he just noticed that it wasn't
symmetrical and was shoddy workmanship
which causes gyoko to explode in anger
screaming at majero he uses his blood
demonard ten thousand gliding slime fish
but the mr shearer dodges with complete
ease he then uses missed breathing sixth
form lunar dispersing mist which manages
to cut all of the fish that kyoku had
released however when those said fish
are killed by a mature and sword they
spray a poison which is absorbed by the
skin just before they turn to dust
because of this gyoku has a quick moment
to ensure michiro's demise however to
kyoko's complete surprise muchuro uses
his missed breathing third form
scattering missed splash which manages
to make all of the poison that was
falling down towards tokito fly off then
with the momentum gained from his
previous attack he cuts into gyoko's
neck but just as he begins to cut
through he realized at that moment that
kyoko had begin to appear on a nearby
tree while transforming into a new form
one of which only two other people had
ever seen he tells tokito that his
transparent scales are stronger than
diamonds and to kneel down before his
perfect beautiful form but in a complete
contrast to kyoko's expectations muchiro
doesn't react any differently to his new
form which fills gyouko with rage he
dives towards muchero and goes to hit
him with more demonic fish however
mature manages to escape and flees to a
nearby tree branch while still on the
branch gyoho asks muchiro what he thinks
of his speed and his god-like power
which can turn anything or anyone he
touches with his fists into his adorable
fish after gyoko has finished his
monologue about his perfect beauty
mature antagonizes him some more saying
that even the strongest attacks are
pointless if they do not hurts mature
thinks back to his master's words
remembering that if he digs in with both
feet he can use his full strength and
that if he knows who he is then no demon
can ever run when you are bringing down
a blade that knows no hesitation or
confusion he urges himself to remember
the boiling anger when he saw maggots
crawling all over his brother's rotted
body and how he himself became infested
with those said maggots slowly being
eaten alive he thinks that even if he
loses his memory his body will remember
the anger they will not leave him until
his death that is the true reason as to
why he is trained so hard to the point
of vomiting blood as kyoku rushes at
tokito he tells him to behold his true
magnificence before using his blood
demon heart killer fish scales hyoko
says that his scales make it unable to
predict his law-defying movements and
begins wondering what he should turn
machero into after he kills him but
taquito uses misbreathing seventh form
obscuring clouds to disorientate the
enemy he then appears and seems to
vanish whenever gyoko attempts to attack
him goku was confused as he looks for
the slayer only to find that the whole
place has been entirely enveloped and
missed all of a sudden mature then
appears as he utters the words asking
the demon if he had actually thought
that he was the only one who wasn't
being serious before as he says these
words the demon's head gets completely
sliced in half cutting him from the base
of his neck decapitating him in that
moment gyoko is confused as to why
everything is upside down all of a
sudden as his head flies through the air
and falls to the ground as this happened
muchiro tells him that this is the end
goodbye you don't ever need to be reborn
yoho begins screaming and becomes
enraged at his complete disbelief when
he realized he's been beheaded by a mere
child it is then revealed that mochiro
drastically changed the speed of his
movements to disorientate the enemy and
that when he wants to he can go really
slow or really fast with the higher
speeds even exceeding gyokos gyoko then
starts completely freaking out about how
he can't lose to such a low life form he
tells tokito that he is with a hundred
of him and that he is a chosen one as he
yells at muchero he gets halfway through
calling him a maggot but before he can
get it out his head is completely sliced
into bits by tokito as he tells him to
just go to hell already immediately
after muchiro toquito defeated gyoko
kanamori was extremely concerned for his
health but taquito was convinced he was
fine even though his health was
obviously deteriorating when kozo kept
persisting for machero to actually
realise he is heard he instead insisted
that he was fine and asked him to check
up on kotetsu but as he says this
muchero starts vomiting foam from the
mouth due to the poison that had finally
reached his blood circulation and
because of this he passed out koji
begins panicking and calls haganezuka to
help him but instead kotetsu shows up
beside him and told him to put mishiro
on his side kozu instantly remarks that
this must be the ghost of the boy
kotetsu bakutsu insisted that he wasn't
a ghost and goes on to prove that the
wound on his arm is extremely deep and
he may die if he does not stop the
bleeding though when it came to his
stomach the help that tanchito had
entrusted to him to put back on its new
katana had ended up saving him meanwhile
mushura was having a flashback of
kuchiro and goku supporting him and
doing their best his father then
appeared behind him patting his back
comforting him and telling him that it
all worked out
uchiro suddenly appeared telling his
younger brother that he had done well as
mature wakes from his flashback it flies
over to tanjuro who was still fighting
against the other remaining demon
tanjulo thinks to himself that there are
five dragon heads that can stretch
around 20 yards as he thinks he has
figured something out he begins to use
hinokami kagura clear blue but is
immediately stopped by one of the
demon's scream attacks sitting in him
flying back and crashing into the trees
as he tries to stand back up he begins
vomiting and realizes his eardrums had
burst making it almost impossible to
stand due to the dizziness when another
attack comes flying in tantrum barely
manages to escape having his foot almost
completely crushed by the shock wave
tangible realizes that the demon can use
the strength of the previous kiduraku
demons and that the overall power of its
attacks are increasing as he barely
manages to dodge another attack he is
caught completely off guard by its
technique as it stretches out and
attempts to chomp down on him again just
as tangible gets caught by the demon's
attack the love hashera finally makes
her arrival apologising for barely
making it in time kanroji tells tangido
to just rest and that he had done a
great job before proceeding to yell at
the upper rank 4 demon to give back both
niziko and genya but immediately gets to
shut up as only one person in this world
can ever give him orders the demon child
uses crazed cry of thunder death but
kanjiro easily counters using love
breathing cat love a shower it is
revealed that matsuri sword is very thin
and flexible the speed of her techniques
past that of even tengan uzowie that
speed is made possible not only by the
flexibility of a powerful katana but by
her own flexibility and incredible range
of motion her katana is extremely
difficult to use and is liable to injure
anyone else who uses it making a weapon
that only she can use as the fight
continues matsuri uses her love
breathing seeking form love pangs and
love breathing sixth form cat leg wins
of love consecutively zohar tuken the
child demon notices that she is keeping
up with the speed and decides to try and
smother her with a flurry of his
techniques he then uses blood demon art
countless striking trees but matsuri
uses her love breathing fifth floor my
swaying love wild claw to cut through
the attack reaching zoho tarkin's body
as tanjido sees this he shouts at her
that he is not hunting his real body
which causes kanruji to get caught right
in the firing range azohaku-tin then
releases his blood demon art compressed
sound waves which matsuri had no other
choice but to face the attack head on as
matsuri is left paralyzed and begins to
lose consciousness the demon realizes
that she has an immense strength and
decides that because she is a special
constitution he is going to eat her and
says that eating her superior flesh will
directly lead to gaining strength as he
ferociously bears down on her head
maturity's life flashes right before her
eyes and she remembers her first fiancee
telling her that only a bear boy or cow
would take her as their wife along with
continuing to insult her hair color he
says that it makes him shudder just to
think about it being passed on to his
children then tells you to forget about
him and the fact that their marriage
interview had ever happened i then
explained that mitsuri has a special
muscle composition her arms are thin and
look weak but her muscle density is
actually eight times that of a regular
humans at 14 months old she was able to
pick up a 33 pound pickling stone she
had an almost unsustainable appetite
eating almost the same amount as three
sumo wrestlers the day her marriage was
called off she decided to hide all of
her peculiar traits until one day a man
appeared saying that he wanted to marry
her as she suddenly gets snapped back
into reality kanroji finds that tangero
nezuko and genya had managed to save her
from sohakuten's first tangero and genya
say that matsuri is their last hope
encouraging her to get back up and fight
hansengu releases another attack however
matsuri manages to get up in time and
cuts through his attack protecting the
four of them all the while matsudi is
screaming at hantengu saying that she
will not let her comrades die as the
demon slayer core is an important place
to her as she goes into another
flashback she remembers kagaya telling
matsudi that she is a special person
chosen by the gods and she should be
proud of her strength telling her that
whoever speaks ill of her actually just
fears her talent maturity sincerely
thanks her father and mother all of the
demon slayers who had taken her in all
of the people she had protected and a
guru for giving her her striped socks
she rethinks how she wondered if it was
okay to be strong because she was a girl
and realizes that she herself suppressed
her own strength out of fear but she
isn't like that anymore she has driven
to protect people back in reality as she
flies forward she cuts through
hantenku's attack and urges herself to
get stronger tanjuro genya and nezuko
start looking for hantengu's real body
while matsuri deals with the other
hansengu notices the trio looking for
the body and tries releasing an attack
their way but it is cut down by matsuri
before it can reach them matsuri is
moving faster than before and hentingu
doesn't know how he then notices a
birthmark on his chest start to grow and
remarks that it looks similar to a demon
pattern hensenku releases another attack
but matsuri easily cuts through it
meanwhile kenya tanjido and niziko are
fighting a tree that is controlled by
hinting and his real body is hit inside
it but they cannot cut it while your
arms are occupied holding onto the tree
which leaves genya no choice but to eat
the tree it is then revealed that kenya
cannot use the breath but instead has
the special ability to temporarily
inherit the traits of the demon if he
eats their flesh the top part of the
tree falls to the ground after genya
eats the lower part of the plant cutting
through the trunk of the tree tanjuro
then attempts to cut the tree up but is
blocked by the branches which act like
whips as this happens nisiko sets the
tree and tangero's sword on fire with
her blood and tangier uses dance of the
fire god flame waltz to cut the tree in
half to reach the hollow inside where
hantengu's real body is but
unfortunately he already made his escape
as tanjiru screams at hantengu saying
that he will make the demon pay for
every sin he has committed hunting gu
remembers someone saying that everything
he does in his life is his
responsibility but he says that he
hasn't done anything wrong in his entire
life in that moment kenya screams at him
calling him a throwing an entire
tree towards the miniature hentengu
niziko and tanjiro duck as kenya angrily
rips trees from their roots and throws
them at hansengu despite ripping out
numerous trees each one fails to
accurately hit hanshengu niziko then
emerges and attempts to quickly swipe at
hansengu but he evades her and quickly
speeds off thinking of what to do
tanjulo recalls a conversation he had
with zinetsu regarding total
concentration he circulates air
throughout the fibers and his muscles
and the blood in his veins and through
the small conversation tanjuro is able
to quickly blast towards entengu in an
instant
as tangero catches hantingu he swings
his flaming blade down and makes contact
with the miniature demon he begins
willing himself with all of his might to
push through but all of a sudden the
tiny hentangu transforms into a
grotesque oversized demon screaming at
tangido asking him whether or not he
felt sorry for him hentinku grabs a hold
of tanjiru's face and begins to attempt
to crush his head but just before he is
able to do so ginyu makes it in time and
plies the fingers of the demon away from
tangero's head while he does this nezuko
flies over top and instantaneously
lights the transfer demon on fire but
this also affects kenya because he had
eaten some of hantinghu's flesh as he
backs away from the burning pile of
bodies they slip off the side of the
cliff and smash onto the ground below
hentingu begins to worry as his
counterpart currently fighting kanroji
is using too much strength not leaving
him with enough to escape he thinks to
himself that he must replenish himself
with human flesh and notes that there
are three sword smiths nearby he
concludes that he will first power up by
eating those three humans and then make
his escape estanjudo struggles behind he
goes to use total concentration to kick
himself towards hentingu but all of a
sudden a katana flies through the air
and landed right in front of tangido
giving him the perfect opportunity to
finally defeat the demon as he wonders
who threw the sword he can see an
intensely injured muchero screaming at
him to use the blade tanjulo grips the
blade and thanks everyone before using
hinokamikagura dancing flash to
completely decapitate the demon finally
ending their struggle
as the first lot of dawn singles
daybreak tangier realizes this and tries
to tell neziko to go and hide in the
shade but this only hits delhi is
causing nezuko to run his way in worry
he yells at niziko to go hide in the
shade but then notices niziko is
pointing at hinting's decapitated body
which is still moving and attacking the
villagers tangero looks at the
decapitated head and reads resentment
written on the tongue of the body where
there should be the word fear meaning
that the body tangibly decapitated was
not the real one before tangero can take
any action to find the real body the
rays of light from the rising sun
reached niziko which causes her to begin
to burn up tangier shields her with his
body and tells her to shrink smaller but
this is all for naught as she is still
getting burned and all the others are
too far away to help him he realizes
that hang tengu's body will get to the
villages before he can put nezuko in the
box and save them leaving him with an
almost impossible decision but before he
can even make it nezuko kicks him in the
direction of the villagers and smiles as
she sacrifices herself for the sake of
the villagers tanger cries as he decides
that he needs to find the real body
running in the direction of the fake
body he starts by sniffing out the real
body finding that it's in the headless
body's heart as the headless hentingu
catches the villagers tangero lands
directly in front of him and tells
hintengu that now it's time to pay for
his sins
because of these words memories from
hantinghu's previous life flash before
his eyes revealing who the demon slayer
truly was just before tangero slices
through the headless demon into
hantengu's real body hid inside his
heart finally cutting his head off this
time tangero instantly collapses on the
ground in sadness and exhaustion as he
realizes that he has won the fight but
in the same moment he has lost his
sister but as tanjiru weeps the
villagers shake him and point in the
direction behind him to the complete
surprise of everyone standing in the sun
healed and uninjured as nezuko looking
more stunning than evo tangero stares in
utter disbelief as his sister greets him
under the warmth of the sun for the
first time in years
skipping away from niziko we go over to
tamiyos where she is writing a letter
mean fatanjido in the letter she thanks
him for giving her the blood of the 12
kazuki moons and niziko
she tells him that the components of
niziko's blood changed in a very short
span of time and explains that she
thinks the reason nezuko hasn't been
able to regain her consciousness is
because she has been prioritizing
something else she says that she thinks
neziko will soon be able to conquer the
sun
it then jumps back to nezuko and tanjuro
tangero shakes nezuko and cries tears of
happiness as he asks sinesiko if she has
become human again but her only response
is a misarray of happy words tangita
realizes that even though she is
standing in the sun she still has fangs
in the eyes of a demon tantru is in
disbelief that she is fine and hugs
nisiko while he cries with joy niziko
pats his head and smiles as ginya
watches the display and smiles too
changido soon passes out due to
exhaustion and in the distance matsuri
screams as she loses her strength just
as the body of hantegushi was fighting
disintegrates to dust
in another place a maid and a child's
mother walk in on muzan disguised as a
child cackling and glee before cutting
the head off the child's mother the maid
stares at muzan and horror as he talks
about how there is no more need for the
blue spider lily when all he needs to do
now is find niziko and devour her then
he can finally conquer the sun we then
go into another flashback where we find
out why muzan wanted this blue spider
lily so much there was once a generous
doctor that had turned muzan into a
demon to try and save him muzan had been
angered that he would not live longer
than 20 due to his worsening sickness
even though he had suffered so much just
to only live a little bit longer because
of this he killed the doctor out of rage
but after killing him he realized that
the medicine the doctor had given him
had made him stronger he had obtained a
strong body but could no longer walk in
the sun angered by this he tried to make
the medicine but he didn't have the blue
spider lily that had been used to make
it he searched and searched and searched
for the blue spider lily flower but he
never found anything the only person who
knew how to make it was the doctor who
he had killed muzan had wanted the
perfect immortal body and now that
niziko had conquered the sun all of the
battles will be centered around her and
they will be ever the more dangerous
than before
back in the main group mature thanks
tanjiro for helping him get something
important back just before kanroji
crashes into all of them hugging the
entire group exclaiming that they had
finally won
well that there officially brings us to
the very end for the one and only
swordsmith village arc of demon slayer
if you guys have enjoyed the video and
want to see more stuff just like this
like more explained videos for different
anime series then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with the algorithm and pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people which honestly is just absolutely
amazing and i can't thank you all for
like how far i've come throughout this
year if you guys want to support me more
then be sure to go over and check out my
patreon and uh thank you to all of the
people who have already like gone over
and done that so far i really can't
thank you guys enough for actually
checking that out and going over there
and hitting that up but anyway enough of
all that kind of jargon if you guys have
any suggestions for up and coming videos
obviously be sure to go down in the
comments section and let me know what
you kind of want me to go over in the
future perhaps but yeah anyway enough of
that i hope you have all enjoyed the
video but for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i
will see you all in a bit goodbye
[Music]